E
.
NEWLY REVEALED DOCUMENTS PROVE
THEY KNEW IT WAS FALSE AND KEPT
SAYING WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE OF
THE REPORTING HE IS THE AUTHOR
OF HER TOPIA.
THANK YOU FOR COMING UNCRATE AM
NOT SURE IF I SUMMARIZE THAT
FAIRLY, BUT WOULD WE KNOW NOW?
>> I DON'T KNOW I THINK WE KNOW
A LOT ABOUT HOW THESE RUSSIA
STORIES CAME TO BE.
PEOPLE JUST LIED AND IN THIS
CASE, EVEN WHEN TWITTER HAD MOR
OR LESS CONCLUSIVE PROOF THAT
THERE WERE NO RUSSIANS INVOLVED
IN THE RELEASE, THAT MEMO #EVEN
WHEN THEY PLEADED WITH MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE NOT TO GO PUBLIC
BECAUSE IT WOULD MAKE THEM LOOK
QUOTE FOOLISH.
THEY WENT AHEAD AND DID IT
ANYWAY DESPITE BEING INFORMED O
THE TRUTH THAT OF COURSE TWITTE
NEW INTERNALLY BECAUSE THEY WER
LOOKING AT THE RAW DATA THIS IS
I THINK A TEMPLATE OF HOW THESE
STORIES CAME TO BE.
POLITICIANS IN THE MEDIA JUST
SIMPLY OVERRODE WHAT THE FACTS
WERE AND THINGS BEING THE WAY
THEY WERE COMMITTED THERE WAS A
REAL MANIA AT THE THAT TIME,
THIS WAS THE PEAK OF THE Mc
CARTHY HYSTERIA ABOUT THE
SUBJECT.
THERE WAS JUST NO TURNING BACK.
THINKING FIVE YEARS LATER IS, W
ARE ENGAGED IN A HOT OR WITH
RUSSIA.
I WONDER HOW MUCH OF THIS WAS T
DIVERT ATTENTION FROM THINGS
THEY DIDN'T WANT EXPOSED AND HO
MUCH OF IT WAS AN EFFORT TO LIF
AMERICANS INTO A FRENZY ABOUT
RUSSIA.
>> I THINK AT THAT TIME, IT
SEEMED MUCH MORE ABOUT DIVERTIN
ATTENTION FROM THE NEW NAZ MEMO
BECAUSE THERE WERE TWO SETS OF
BIG STORIES THEY CAME OUT AT TH
TIME AND ONE WAS THAT THE STORY
WAS BEING AMPLIFIED BY RUSSIAN
BOTS, AND THAT STORY WAS
REPEATED BY VIRTUALLY EVERY
MAJOR NEWS ORGANIZATION IN
AMERICA AND OTHER COUNTRIES AS
WELL LIKE THE CDC DID THAT STORY
.
THE OTHER STORY WAS THE NUNEZ
MEMO WAS NOT JUST FAKE, AND NOT
JUST COMPLETELY DEVOID OF ANY
IMPORTANT REVELATIONS, BUT THE
GROUNDS FOR HIM TO POTENTIALLY
BE REMOVED FROM HIS POSITION AT
THE INTEL COMMITTEE.
INTEL.ORG HAD A COMMITTEE ON
THAT BIRD WE FOUND OUT TWO YEAR
LATER THAT VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING
AND THE NUNEZ MEMO HAD BEEN
PROVED CORRECT.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE
DOING WAS JUST TRY TO DEFLECT
FROM AN UNCOMFORTABLE TRUTH BY
CALLING HIM UP RUSSIAN PROXY.
>> Tucker: REALLY QUICK SINCE
I KNOW YOU'RE KEEPING SCORE, HA
ANY NEWS ORGANIZATION APOLOGIZE
NOW IN LIGHT OF THE TRUTH COMIN
OUT?
>> NOT ONLY HAVE THEY NOT
APOLOGIZED, BUT ARE NOT ONE OF
THE NEWS ORGANIZATIONS THAT I
REACHED OUT TO FOR COMMENT ABOU
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE RESPONDED
TO ME.
WHICH SUGGESTS TO ME THAT THEY
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED THEY
KNOW EXACTLY HOW RESPONSIBLE
THEY WERE.
AGAIN, THIS ISN'T LEFT OR RIGHT
ISSUE, THIS IS A FACT ISSUE THA
THEY NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO ASK
TWITTER WHAT WAS GOING ON.
I DON'T THINK MOST OF THESE NEW
ORGANIZATIONS DID THAT AND NOW
THEY ARE RELUCTANT TO AD